could the coming 2022 midterm election
be the worst midterm ever for
republicans in this particular situation
the situation being one that should be
very good for the republican party if
you look historically i know many of you
are sick of hearing this from me but i
want to remind everybody normally when
one party takes the white house from the
other party in the first midterm
election after that
that very party then loses a bunch of
seats or potentially control of the
house or senate meaning because
democrats took the white house from
republicans in 2020 2022 should be very
very good for republicans and it was
looking that way for a very long time
and all of a sudden in the last month
and in particular in the last two weeks
things are looking dramatically
different we mentioned yesterday
the senate has approved this inflation
reduction act bill to fight climate
change and cut drug costs this is a
major accomplishment assuming that the
house passes it on friday and then it is
signed by joe biden both of which are
expected to happen
this is a massive biden accomplishment
and then when you look bigger picture at
the biden accomplishments you see
that he did the covet stimulus he did
the infrastructure and jobs act he
confirmed the first black female supreme
court justice he did some gun safety
legislation although i think it's pretty
weak sauce but at least it was something
he did the chips act for semiconductor
manufacturing the nato expansion to
include finland and sweden is in process
he expanded veterans health care
he authorized the strike that killed
terrorist ayman al-zawahiri which
believe me i understand there are legal
questions about
whether the united states can or should
be doing that but it is an
accomplishment that biden can claim
fantastic jobs report last week
3.5 unemployment 55 straight days of gas
price reduction which again remember i
don't even think it has anything to do
with biden i don't think the upswing had
anything to do with biden i don't think
the downswing has anything to do with
joe biden either but the point is what
is reported and what can you take credit
for and tomorrow
we have an inflation number coming out
which i expect to be significantly lower
than the peak numbers we saw over the
last few months i may be wrong but
that's what i expect and if that's the
case it will be another indicator that
the economy is looking better and better
overall
could this be
a disastrous midterm for republicans
well the polling data is increasingly
pointing that way
after looking
for months and months like republicans
were going to take the senate
definitively from democrats in the fall
the 538 uh forecast for the senate now
has democrats at 59 percent likely to
retain control of the senate now
that's not overwhelming
but it is looking increasingly good for
democrats in terms of the senate now in
the house it's not looking very good it
still looks like about an eighty percent
chance that republicans win remember
eighty percent is not a hundred percent
but that's the way that it is looking
right now
this is a massive massive reversal from
the way things looked and quite frankly
the way things should look speaking
historically for republicans
what do you think we're going to see in
november and then the last piece of this
is we spoke about this a little bit with
political scientist rachel bittikoffer
last week she has a slightly different
view on it than i do and i know many of
you have different views about this
because of the overturning of roe v wade
this actually does seem like it is a
midterm election
where running on abortion rights on
women having autonomy over their medical
decisions
could be very good for democrats
typically it is not an issue that is so
good for democrats
uh extraordinary circumstances and as
i've said before there are some
elections which just don't feel like
they're that important the 2022 midterm
and the 2024 presidential election which
are honestly one in the same i mean the
24 election is almost getting going
right now and we're going to look at
some of those numbers later as well
because what is happening with trump and
desantis is extraordinary
could this be a disaster for republicans
let me know what you think